[Music]
mention my name is Jean all the stuff is
in these places which is called
Picasso's
terminal so because and this is really I
know there's been already a lot of
machine learning discussed here I looked
at the schedule and there's at least
three sessions with tensorflow and caris
have been brought up and discussed here
and I guess this talk is going to be a
little offbeat for me because I usually
talk a lot to artists and designers and
not in any usually I mean it's sort of
like proper Python conference and this
is going to be all about how you can
sort of make the most financially
suboptimal use of your machine learning
skills if you're so inclined and I'll
kind of start by telling you a little
bit about myself and how I once you know
I was once a sort of once promising data
scientist now turned into sort of
struggling to make ends meet with with
these kinds of skills kind of a joke but
not really so I started out in this
field called music information retrieval
how many people are familiar with with
Mir a good number this is the
application of machine learning to audio
so if you've ever listened to like
Spotify and you've gotten music
recommendations a lot of this is
actually now driven by music information
retrieval which is taking audio content
and then trying to learn to to infer
various sort of metadata about it like
what genre it belongs to or sort of
music illogical information and this is
what I was doing about maybe nine eight
to nine years ago and at the time
machine learning was totally different
as we all know there's been a lot of
progress in and a few things that I'll
talk about this was a mostly an audio
dominated field like most of my skills
were in audio signal processing and
machine learning was actually kind of a
small part of it for reasons that I'll
kind of just get into at the same time I
have something of a predilection for
more artistic projects so I was working
a lot with a friend of mine named Jeff
Schneider on building machine learning
controlled musical instruments he is a
designer of electronic instruments that
look like this so this is called a
barrel an electronic wind instrument
and what we did was we developed an
interface that would let you train it to
respond to the various inputs you give
it so it has a bunch of capacitive touch
sensors and a breath pressure and
embouchure sensor to sense the pressure
to sense the shape of your milk on it
and what we you could do is then train a
physical model to convert the input
sensors that are on the the instrument
into the synthesis parameters that are
making the sound and this kind of
inverts the traditional notion of a
musical instrument we think of it
usually as something that you have to
learn how to play and that's a big
barrier to being creative and expressive
with musical instruments you have to
learn actually how to physically
maneuver them but this kind of makes
that backwards it makes it so that the
instrument learns how you want it to be
played which really we think kind of
greatly enables people to kind of become
much more creative with instruments very
quickly at the same time of all I've
also had sort of a dual practice as what
we call like a creative coder or a new
media artist I'm really interested in
creating interactive installations like
the kind that you see here these are
these are videos from a toolkit called
connect projector toolkit which I
developed to facilitate the calibration
of connect you know the depth cameras
made by Microsoft and others to
projectors so that you could do sort of
like body reactive projection mapping
and work with dancers and theater people
and things like that this is kind of at
a time where I was thinking like well I
really want to get off the computer
screen and kind of work with people in
live-action and that kind of spurred the
development of this and for me these
were always like these are always two
very very separate fields you know kind
of two separate sides of me I was doing
a lot of machine learning and even the
stuff that was connected with music it
still felt much more academic and niche
than compared to the media arts practice
which is you know probably you know a
very very still very very distance from
from the kind of interests that are
found here but this kind of all started
to change about two years ago when we
started to see neural networks and
different machine learning algorithms
creating really interesting compelling
visual art maybe some of you already
recognize some of these because a lot of
them made certainly even even with
respect to the kind of press
we see with machine learning nowadays
they made a lot of a lot of waves online
so like how many people here it's a deep
dream I'm going to talk about deep dream
in a minute at least half of you which
is which is impressive and then these
are some of the I'm going to talk about
each of these in order so so if any of
these images appeal to you you'll hear a
lot more about how they're made but for
me this was kind of a big moment because
it was the first time that I saw people
that I associated with in the media arts
world taking an interest in machine
learning which had up to then been a
very very like academic topic right and
the kind that's reserved to conferences
like this not so much to the art world
and so I began to kind of double down my
focus on on this area to try to kind of
do a little bit more work at that
intersection I won't I'm not going to be
labor and like the exhibition machine
learning because all of you have
probably beaten over the head with it
all weekend but of course like most
machine learning can fall under this
category right here you're trying to
learn you're trying to approximate some
unknown function right and you can use a
data set to combine to the learning
algorithm like a stochastic gradient
descent or something like that or some
flavor of it to learn that function but
then you know X&Y don't have to be you
know don't have to be just solved for
solving problems like predicting how
much it's going to rain or what the
price of a stock is going to be the next
day X&Y can actually be images and they
can be doing interesting transformations
of media in general to make very
unexpected results I'm going to show you
just a few of those of course this has
all been enabled by neural networks
which had a big comeback neural networks
as you know these were really really
exciting in like the 50s and 60s and
that was the Golden Age of AI you know
for people who are watching you know or
reading science fiction and you know in
those times or watching The Jetsons as I
did as a kid well you know they're
reruns by then but you know that the 60s
were this hyper utopian sort of
futuristic dreams that we're that were
kind of the result of a lot of hype that
came about in the late 50s and early 60s
about neural networks
and you know the assumption was that as
we scale these things up they're going
to solve intelligence basically and we
know that didn't didn't happen there was
a big crash over the next couple of
decades that and it's only really really
just in the last almost five years or so
and that's been enabled by a lot of the
you know everyone's been hearing about
deep learning I'm going to get into in
just a second and and this is and I'm
going to kind of try to build up to why
this has affected visual art in such a
big way and the reason has a lot to do
with computer vision which is a topic
that's been very close to my heart for a
long time because computer vision is
Etta is at the heart of interactive
installation so you make cameras that
look at people and then do interesting
things with the images or make
generative art based on camera feeds and
computer vision was this field that up
until again like five years ago would
have looked more like this and this was
this characterized computer vision as a
machine learning as a subject of machine
learning or as an objective of machine
learning I in the 90s and 2000's you
would have a pipeline that would
normally look like this you would have
some input image and then you would do
some sort of handcraft what we might
call handcrafted feature extraction
which means that you have this toolbox
of feature extra features that are
useful for computer vision so like the
ones you're looking at here or what are
called the Hogs features histogram of I
think histograms of oriented gradients
which basically create a histogram of
the dominant vectors that you find in
the segmented image and this is
necessary because pixels are very
meaningless information by themselves
you need to be able to create some sort
of statistical representation of the
data in order to do learning on top of
it and then you would plug those
features into a learning algorithm now
the problem with this approach is that
it was really time consuming and
expensive so if you're a computer vision
researcher you would spend 90% of your
time implementing you know lots of
different features trying to experiment
with different features seeing what
would work best with one task which may
not be the same for another task you
might have to use totally different
features and even for me when I was
getting started in audio most of my time
was spent on
audio feature extraction so doing a lot
of DSP signal processing and then 10% of
the time you are really kind of
experimenting with machine learning and
if anyone was programming at this time
you'd know that all the stuff was just
all over the place some of it was in
that lab and some of it wasn't C and
then some of it was in you know Fortran
and God knows where you know be like all
over the place and there just be a ton
of engineering involved in maintaining
all of these libraries in and then
plugging them into whatever you know
classifier that you were going to use
for your task and of course if you were
a computer vision researcher you would
have to learn a whole nother field if
you wanted to get into audio or vice
versa and this was changed in a big way
because know starting in the most last
few years because of the emergence of
deep learning deep learning has created
neural networks which have basically
just swallowed this entire process of
feature extraction and operate basically
on the raw media and that means that if
you're a computer vision researcher that
means you can just jump straight into
audio or into text or begin working with
self-driving cars and that's that's been
really like the most exciting thing
because now we've eliminated so much of
the overhead involved in creating robust
machine learning algorithms they'd
become much more accurate as well as a
result of this and so that's been the
precursor to all this excitement that
we're hearing about today so how does
this well yeah let's let's talk about
how that works so most people I know
there was I think I talked about this
yesterday about convolutional networks
and I'm going to show you like a really
quick demo of how they work let's hope
it works yeah so this is a live cub net
running inside my presentation window
this is all being run in something
called open frameworks by the way for
those who are interested in how I put
slides and demos together so so come
let's do feature extraction and a layer
by layer in the layer by layer sequence
so at the first layer you're seeing that
it has a whole bunch of filters that are
able to extract mostly just edges edges
or patches of consistent color or really
just like really primitive multiple
pixel patterns right and
then after you do some normalization and
what's called pulling pulling is just
down sampling you have a smaller but
more meaningful representation of the
original image because instead of having
just raw pixels you have detected small
features like edges right and then what
you do is you have a new set of
convolutional filters that look for
patterns among the patterns that were
found in the last convolution that's as
much as I can like say into in a
two-minute summary of course you can you
can take whole classes about these but
that's that's really kind of the gist of
KUB Nets they do
pattern recognition among patterns that
were found in the previous later which
were patterns themselves of other
patterns that were found from the
original pixels and that's really what's
going on here we can go through this
layer by layer and acquire at each layer
a higher and higher level representation
of the original image until you can find
some that you can even interpret I like
to go to come for 156 this is my
favorite let's see I think that's it
yeah you see that that looks like a face
detector right in fact you can even see
that on the feedback here's a little
right there there's a little bit of my
face there yeah in fact but I have some
faces here in front of me I think yeah
it's a little there we go so yeah so and
then finally at the end you have this
really really concise representation of
the original image and then you can do
classification on top of it right so
like this is a wig of course that's
always the first thing that comes up
when I put my face in front of it or an
iPod cellular telephone skews this neck
brace
okay so doesn't have everything right a
mouse just and all right tell telephone
telephone that's not so bad right okay
well let's continue right so like what
can we do with all this well first of
all at cub nets are everywhere they're
involved and they've pretty much taken
over computer vision for almost every
task associated with TV you
have convolutional net works behind the
scenes they're involved in making
self-driving cars they're even in areas
like speech-to-text processing because
you can really think of it as almost
like an image problem you have a
spectrogram you can look at the sort of
frequency by time activities of the of
the sound and then convert that into
text and even things like alphago how
many people are familiar with alphago
story last year lots of people of course
so that was when beat line which is
right here of course in nearby developed
an AI that played the game of go and
beat the world's top-ranked player so
that was a really big landmark moment
and cub nets were part of a sort of
ensemble system that really effectively
solved to go I think 10 years ahead of
schedule so that was a really big moment
as well and of course they've been
involved in deep dream which I'm going
to start to talk about them I also want
to mention really quickly like a lot a
lot of the really for me the most
inspiring thing to have seen develop in
the last five years is a big community
that's developed around machine learning
when I was getting started and I did I
never went to grad school so I worked
immediately as a like a research
assistant for a small company and at
that time it felt very hard to like
really develop your skills because it
was really esoteric you if you weren't
part of a grad school institution or a
research research lab a lot of the stuff
wasn't it wasn't just online you really
had to be sort of close to two people
who already knew how to do it and that's
changed fundamentally in the last couple
of years so now like with something like
archive.org almost all computer science
papers are being published in peer
peer-reviewed open access sometimes
ahead of conferences like which is
really strange in academia to actually
just put your results up before
conference deadlines before journals and
and in the free and open access way and
so this has made it really easy for
people outside of these kind of research
circles to keep up with the research
there's been of course also like things
like Kaggle which is you know you can
you can as an amateur enter really
really high level machine learning
competitions and actually make money
from it and then of course there's also
lots of discuss
you know and there's a very active
machine learning channel on reddit and
there's a lot of a lot of the
researchers are on Twitter and
constantly kind of exchanging
recommendations of papers and discussing
the latest research of the day and then
the biggest thing really has been the
emergence of these high level mostly
python-based which I'm going to talk
about deep learning frameworks like
tensorflow and even libraries on top of
tensorflow which make the training and
creation of neural networks really
really short easy to read programs so
things like teres has really made I'm
gonna show carrots in just a moment but
has made and I know there was two
sessions about carrots yesterday so you
guys have seen how just how easy it has
become to actually train your own neural
networks this is a much more recent
thing maybe some of you have heard about
PI torch which is a Python app ipython
based version of torch which was sort of
competing frameworks to tensorflow which
does very effective and much more sort
of dynamic and flexible framework for
machine learning for deep learning
called torch which was previously you
can only interact with it through Lua
which is a programming language I don't
know how many of you know it I don't so
it's been really nice to kind of see a
lot of the stuff has been converging on
Python which is the sort of preferred
preferred language of data scientists
these days so as I said Kerris makes
makes it really easy to to train deep
neural networks and what you're looking
at is a 31 line piece of code most of
which is just creating the architecture
of the network that it solves m-miss so
M this is a handwritten digits data set
it's kind of the hello world of most
machine learning and this if you run
this insight you can learn this on any
laptop these days it will give you a 99%
accuracy an N missed digit recognition
which would have been the world's record
up until as recently as I think 2005
something around then the 31 line
program which gives you the state of the
art and from 2005 obviously I'm not has
happened since 2005 but
but it's really worth noting what a
difference this is between now and when
you know it when this would have been a
who knows how many line program written
in you know I will even noticed anything
I wasn't around to notice it so list or
fortunate or something okay so let's
talk more about art that's that's kind
of what everyone is here for so how many
of you saw this image in 2015 anybody
see this this is kind of like this is
the original deep dream so this was
posted to the machine-learning subreddit
the channel of Reddit for machine
learning and it was it was posted by an
anonymous poster who wrote image
generated by a convolutional neural
network and it's this weird-looking slug
squirrel thing right and immediately
reddit erupted in pure like where could
this image have been where could this
image have come from and people had seen
this kind of stuff in the research so
people had been working on sort of
visualizing class class visualization in
with convolutional networks by changing
the pixels so as to maximize activations
within a neural Everitt but no one had
ever seen something like this right and
then a few days later Google team of
researchers at Google had had introduced
what they called deep dream and what
deep dream was was building on some
research as I mentioned from the
previous year where they had where
people had been working on one of the
common complaints with these kumkum nets
is that you don't really know what's
going on inside of them and so one way
of kind of mitigating that is to develop
algorithms which will synthesize images
which activate certain neurons so if you
want to know what a particular region of
the network is looking for you can
actually synthesize an image which will
maximally activate that part of the
network and that was that was the basis
of what deep dream came from but what
deep dream was was kind of a was a one
step further and the very clever one
actually I think we can all agree
what it did was instead of just
synthesizing images from scratch it
would start with a real image let's say
this photograph from a savanna somewhere
and it would pass it through a neural
network a cub net and observe all the
activations and then change the pixels
adjust them slightly ever so slightly
iteratively
so as to make the network see more of
the things that it thinks it sees right
so if the network is detecting weird
camels and or pigs nails or what they
call Admiral dogs the network would
actually basically hallucinate properly
hallucinate I think we can we've earned
the right to use that I think for for
this technique because you know even if
it seems just a little of that it would
just the pixels and just make it see
more of that it would amplify it SaLuSa
nations and create all sorts of really
interesting kind of art stuff so I'm
going to show you some of the things
that came out of that this was so Google
released a again this is July 2015 they
released a Python notebook written in
using tensorflow
oh sorry it was using cafe actually this
is before tensorflow had been released
so cafe is a deep learning framework
that's really popular with with
especially with computer vision
researchers that was developed at
Berkeley and they released the cafe
notebook that you could still use to
this day that would which would guide
you through the process of making your
own dreams and so when I saw this I
immediately started to like apply it to
my photographs and kind of do all sorts
of weird interesting things with it and
it would it would make you know
hallucinate these capsules and dogs and
you know I don't know the neat thing
about it is that you can actually you
can because network is is a sequence of
layers and you can choose which layers
of network you want to enhance maybe you
want to enhance one of the middle layers
where it's looking for more abstract
features sort of like edges or gradients
or maybe you want to enhance one of the
later layers which are looking for whole
objects like these like a lot of dogs
right if you're wondering if you're
wondering why there were so many of
these so called puppy slugs all over the
place that's because the original
network that that deep dream was trained
on
inception Network I was trained on
something like 100 breeds of dogs among
other things so that you see dogs
everywhere dogs dogs I'm so here's a
sketch of Leonardo da Vinci with more of
the puppy slugs kind of a here I really
love how it if they appear from nowhere
on the stairs like you can and of course
you know you can work with different
painters and you know for anyone who saw
this they said just you can just run
anything right and the whole internet
was just littered with you know G dream
paraphernalia like all over the place on
Google Images on Twitter and one of the
researchers who worked in Mike tyka
really kind of took this - new - new new
places so he would do all these
experiments where he would start with
images of random noise just white noise
and of course like deep dream does not
say I don't see anything it'll see
something no matter what you put into it
it'll it'll begin to hallucinate
features from nowhere and he was making
you know images that looked like these
really kind of experimenting with his
technique doing a lot of like making
these infinite fractals so this is this
is something I made but basically based
on Mike tiger's work so here you would
do deep dream white noise but then you
would start to iteratively crop crop it
kind of zooming in and then determining
their resultant and zooming in deep
trimming the result and then just kind
of doing this feedback process and
generating just infinite amount of deep
dream junk right and kind of oscillating
here the which layer you're trying to
enhance and I got some results you know
you can kind of take this technique and
do various things but it's very very
heavy-handed because it really has only
one degree of freedom you know like
which layer you're enhancing and and
maybe you know also what you initialize
it with and so most d3 and kind of look
like this right and so by the end of
like the summer I was seeing like puppy
slugs in my cappuccino really scary
and so that was that was a problem for
me but luckily luckily at the same
roughly around the same time about a
month later style transfer emerge which
is another technique that received think
almost as much attention as a deep
trainer what style transfer was was
technique which regenerates an image in
the style of another image so here's the
Mona Lisa in the form of Picasso van
Gogh and Monet and entirely made by a
neural network and you see you know it's
it's really it's quite realistic it
really captures the style of these
different paintings you can see starry
night here emerging and I was just
amazed at how consistently you can it
would work on any style basically so
different painters this is already like
old actually we have much better
implementations for style transfer that
even looks better than this capture more
sort of high level you know kind of high
level detail Kandinsky and you can just
throw anything you want doesn't have to
do paintings crab nebula Egyptian
hieroglyphs Google Maps
[Laughter]
and you can do video with it and the
first time I tried doing video with it
it just come out and so the only thing
you could really do was was style
transfer each frame individually and
then just make a video out of it and so
you would get results like this and it
would be kind of flickering because it's
a very chaotic process but then what
would happen is but then a few months
later people were like okay well let's
let's try to do this with with video
from the outset and this is a some
software made by these guys Reuter
that's all his team and in late 2016
which generates the whole video at the
same time all of the frames and all it
does is instead of just trying to
optimize the style and content
reconstruction it also adds this optical
flow loss term so it's trying to
minimize the amount of deviations frame
to frame in the optical flow which is a
computer vision technique this is a
video that I took from the window of the
J train in Brooklyn lots of Indian New
Yorkers here a few of course I use
Google Maps for everything you just
can't I can't get enough of you notice
the windows become markers like a new
artifact here okay so let me show you a
quick demo I know so one of the neat
things also is that so the technique
that you were just looking at it
basically does it does it offline it
takes a little while to generate each
image you can actually train a neural
network to do the whole process from
from the start of style transfer and do
it in basically real time so here I have
a camera and it's making this is this is
the basis for an installation I called
cubist mirror which is kind of it's
doing exactly what you see it right so
you see there's a tensorflow script so
you can run this entirely on your
computer and I'm actually I haven't put
this online yet but I'll put it online
like this week the script and the models
so this is doing a real-time cubist
cubist interpretation of the camera feed
and i just want to i want to note also
that you know we think of the dream and
I'm sorry style transfer and deep dream
of things that you need really big
computers to use this is a four year old
MacBook Pro if you run this in the
computer with a decent GPU you can
actually do it at a much faster
much faster level right the keyboard
kind of like saddle me I have multiple
styles so I'm trying to go into the next
one but it's a little bit let's wait for
it come on there we go focus I and then
I have two Hoka sides one those by the
original authors of the software that
I'm using so this is called fast fast
tensorflow
style transfer I think that fast style
transfers and playing up in tensorflow
and so that's hooker say we have a lot
more of these keyboards a little flaky
but it does take then because I'm trying
to change the image with the keyboard
I've got about eleven of these but maybe
we're not going to make it through all
of them so it's not so much these online
well the leaked inch nine one actually
you should see that because that works
best on a face so oh we went to Google
Maps
anyhow you get the idea and this is all
stuff that you can run on your own
computer and of course it works way
faster on them on a nice machine so
let's get out of this want to go back to
the slides which are here
okay
so when we talk about deep generator
networks this is another technique that
was popularized or actually developed a
couple months ago by by these guys who
do a lot of work in visualizing neural
networks and this is really making
almost photorealistic I mean if you look
at these table lamps cell phones
aircraft carriers French loaves these
are all images of actual objects that
are hallucinating by it by neural
networks and we're the amount of
progress that has been observed in the
last year is just staggering because if
you think about it these are these
images are let's say 200 by 200 pixels
so if you think of how many pixels how
many combinations of pixels can possibly
make up an image the fact that we're
able to find this sort of very very low
dimensional manifold through this entire
gigantic pixel space that's able to find
realistic looking images is is like
really really impressive I think and I'm
going to show you just some more
highlights of this this is what's called
a tease me tease me is a visualization
technique for visualizing high
dimensional data in a low dimensional
two or three dimensional space such that
similar images are grouped near to each
other and these are all of these
synthesized classes of a deep generator
network trained on cafe net which is a
data set containing all these objects so
there's a plunger and ladle and iPod a
cellular telephone and similar images
are grouped together so you can kind of
go to some other region up here and here
we found we stumbled upon like the sea
creatures here tiger sharks and
platypuses and gars and great white
sharks there's some snakes I think yeah
king snakes go down here we have the dog
section no no neural network is complete
without a bunch of species of dogs
different mammals there's a bird section
here somewhere there's some food the
food actually the bed there's a section
with them berries I think which are
quite which are quite delicious looking
actually if I say so let me show you
some cool things about this so what
you're looking at is
the way that this network works is that
it basically has something called the DC
guys I haven't talked about deep
convolutional generative adversarial
networks a really neat technique for
creating synthetic images and it's
trying to find this input code which
maximally activates the region of a
network responsible for classifying a
particular object so this is it
struggling to find the input code to the
network which maximizes the network's
classification of the image as a macaw
so here's the macaw looking object this
on the left is a teapot being generated
and on the right is a cheeseburger
delicious which is a really neat thing
that you can do you can visualize these
like you know they're because they're
because each frame is a
realistic-looking image through this
generative space but of a sort of
undefined object which is kind of a neat
thing if you think about it for for
other reasons and I like the way that
people came out as sort of artifacts in
these so a lot of the none of the class
image classes were of people directly
and so it would sort of learn to you
know places that would have people in
them such as a conference centre it
would learn to kind of create these
weird like kind of scary-looking talking
heads which as an artifact of the
process of synthesizing the class which
contains people so you see the nursing
home and you know you have kind of white
hair and floral patterns and there's a
lecture hall here's the legislative
chamber this looks familiar doesn't it a
Golf Course is a weird like headless
golf player I like the basketball court
because I can't tell it whether this is
like a head or a basketball player
shooting a three like this is it a head
or a basketball I can't tell and this is
maybe my favorite of these and I show
this everywhere I go basically she's so
synthesizing both houses and what's cool
is that the you can see that at the
water has reflections of the objects on
top of it and that and that demonstrates
something really subtle about these
covenants which is that they learn sort
of realistic things that
a little bit intangible like the idea
that water has reflections and that's
not information that's properly encoded
ahead of time into the network it just
kind of learned that from examples
except in some cases it forgets what the
thing is and it begins to reflect
something totally different which is
kind of scary and this is some more work
by it by the same guys who develop the
deep generator networks and this is now
they're able to synthesis something
that's really emerging I think you'll
see a lot more of this in the next year
so these are images that are generated
not just from these activation codes but
are actually generated from captions so
you're right okay I want a red car
parked on the side of the road and
here's your red car parked on the side
of the road and it's a little gnarly
looking but in a lot of cases it's we're
entering this this period where we're
very soon we might be able to generate
images from what we say you know we say
okay I want a red car parked on the side
of the road you can think of all sorts
of applications for that and of course
the reverse is true as well so a lot of
these systems are very sort of
multimodal you go text to image or image
to text or image to audio audio to image
and so on and there's kind of just a ton
of research being in this direction so
let me show you one of my favorite
things this is the sort of Swiss Army
knife of convolutional neural network
inspired art so these are this is called
pix depicts how many people saw pix
depicts how many people saw a sketch to
cat that was the thing that I think made
the most wave so that was the thing
online where you draw a picture of a cat
and they'll generate a cat so that is
based on some research made by Philip
Isola it's all just a bit early late
last year where they demonstrated a
canary image to image translation neural
network and at first it was written in
torch so in lua now there's a tensorflow
version so it's in Python something I've
been using a lot and what it does is it
basically learns how to map one kind of
neural network into another map one kind
of image into another with a neural
network so for example if you have a
parallel set of satellite images and
their corresponding maps you can learn
to generate maps from satellite images
or vice versa or maybe something more
functional is is turning black and white
colors into photo or super resolution is
another example of image to image
translation or taking sketches of things
and making photographs out of them or
turning photos of daytime into nighttime
or for example and I work a lot with
design students as Ruby mentioned I work
with design and artist artists and
designers and one thing you can imagine
being in the sort of designing software
of the future is mocking up textures
from skeleton frames things that you
basically draw into an interface so for
example if you're an architect and you
make a label a bunch of labels so here's
like the windows and the doors and the
window sills and things are color coded
and then you can very quickly generate a
texture for it
you know mock-up a texture and kind of
see this thing live and so this is
really kind of the photoshop and
illustrator of the future and and and
true to form adobe is hiring lots of
these kind of the guys making these this
technology hiring them like crazy to
begin to create new features into their
software so I use this for an art
project just a week that it came that
came out a project called invisible
cities I happen to be running a workshop
in Milan Italy in the makerspace called
open dot and we came up with this idea
to download map tiles from map box the
open source street maps provider open
source basically like open source
version of Google Maps so you can get
map tiles that are color coded according
to infrastructure roads and and water
and so on and then the corresponding
satellite imagery and then you can train
a network to convert any map tiles into
the satellite imagery and once you do
that you can see what it looks like it
when it tries to reconstruct the
original inputs so here you see the
reconstruction this is the one on the
right is totally fake this is real since
that this is real satellite imagery this
is a fake reconstruction and it's kind
of weird-looking right it's not exactly
it doesn't look quite realistic but it
is a pretty decent reconstruction almost
like an impressionistic version of
Venice I liked how it even hallucinates
its own boats
here in the middle of nowhere and but
the brilliant idea is what well and this
wasn't even my ideas I don't even
remember whose is one of my students the
idea was to basically take maps house
from one city and run them through the
generative model of another city and do
a sort of study style transfer so this
is Los Angeles in the style of Venice or
Milan and the style of Venice here on
the right so just superimposing the
textural style of an one city onto the
grid of another so Milan styled Los
Angeles and Venice but then you can just
start putting in anything you want
because the network has learned how to
take whatever math tiles you give it you
know if you color-coded water and roads
and infrastructure and and parks and
things like that with with the actual
satellite images you know anything you
give it like a drawing it will create
these you know synthetic terrains very
otherworldly and so that's why we called
it invisible cities named after the book
by Tom Calvino I also made a drawing
tool for this and it was really really
kind of last second that was at a
hackathon and I basically this happened
to be in South Korea so I generated a
model of jet generating the generating
maps of of Seoul and made an interface
that would send it to the server and
then the server would recite it and then
send it back to you and so if you saw
sketch the cat this is basically the
same thing except much better engineered
than anything I could have come up with
so yeah you can have a lot of fun with
this as you can see one of my students
at a recent workshop made this with pix
depicts so here he is using Quartz
Composer little diary Jakub of making
using quartz composer to make like
generative kind of you know rotating
windows and doors and things like that
and then generating facades associated
with them and making really really cool
artifacts from that very similar as
worked by a Dutch artist named Jasper
van lonen who synthesized Street View cm
Street View cityscapes and it's worth
noting because you know people here
there's a Python conference right this
is all like basically command-line
software in
Python and all you need is a data set a
parallel data set of a few hundred
examples to use picks depicts so it's
the kind of thing that if you have at
least access to a decent GPU or an
Amazon Cloud or something like that you
can be doing things like this they even
provide data sets so you can you can be
started with it within you know like an
hour so really kind of a good excuse to
throw away a Saturday afternoon and I'll
initiate the most recent project that I
did with it and this is going to be the
one that is probably maybe the most
offensive because what I did was I took
and this is an idea from a friend of
Mines also a really good neuro regardest
named Mario Clingerman who first used
who first trained picks two picks to
convert face tracker so you can do face
you can do really good face tracking
using like something like d-lab which is
a nice Python or C++ based library with
Python bindings for face tracking and
other computer vision tasks and you so
here I downloaded just a video of Donald
Trump speaking and extracted its face
and made a data set of a few hundred
samples of this and then train a neural
network to convert a face tracker you
know tape basically convert this into
this right and so then you just put your
own face in front of the face tracker
and then begin to hallucinate images of
I should stop using that word too much
and I'm sorry if anyone doesn't if
anyone's offended by the following video
please do look away it is the most
horrible thing that you've seen today
I'll just I'll just quickly point out
that um the same week that that I made
this there's a company called Lyrebird
which came out with some software which
basically mimics people's voices it can
imitate people's voices and make them
say you know whatever you put into it
and so this is really the future we're
looking at where you can I mean this is
really a bad version of this it's just
hacked together but you can do pretty
realistic sort of face imitation and now
you can do voice imitation too so and
that's that's bad things to laugh about
that's like a really something very
crazy that we haven't really considered
that in the future you'll be able to
just completely impersonate someone's
their visage and their voice and who
knows what the consequences that are
going to be is something that we have to
be thinking about I made a really hack
together version of this that runs it on
the webcam and this is really cool that
you could do this live basically because
pix depicts actually training takes a
while but generation is much faster so
you can put people in front of a webcam
this is I had the recent workshop it it
the University ikaw in Lausanne
Switzerland and you see people step in
front of the camera and then begin to
see themselves as Trump it's horrible
right isn't it
yeah recently a friend of mine another
artist who's based right here in London
made memo memo Acton he did a very
similar thing so he's doing Kenny edge
detection on what he draws and he
trained the pics depicts model on a
collection of 150 museums art
collections and so it's just generating
a sort of synthetic museum collection
drawing let's say something it might be
a bad description but something along
those lines in real time on the webcam
and so you can kind of like make a lot
of like now we're we're able to do a lot
of this stuff interactively and in real
time which is pretty interesting I'll
really quickly say some recent research
which is not necessarily much art has
come out of this just yet or but you can
imagine you know just just how cool this
is
so cycle again is this is just for a few
weeks ago I think and it's basically the
same as pix depicts except it doesn't
acquire it does not require parrot
examples it can just you can just train
an unpaired examples and so it can do it
can basically convert all sorts of
things so they showed examples for
converting courses into zebras and
zebras and the horses changing the
seasons of photos so summer to winter
winter in the summer it could do style
transfer you know it's a sort of very
generic framework for doing image
translation or turn paintings into
photos and photos into paintings and
they posted a video that went viral a
few weeks ago of force being turned into
a zebra in real time right which is the
craziest thing right and and notice also
that the pasture is the green pasture
becomes like a brown savannah and that's
sort of like the because it doesn't
actually you don't ever tell it you know
like what is that you're trying to
convert it just kind of learns all the
surrounding features that it needs to
and I want to put your attention on
another one thing which is notice that
every time the zebra passes by that pole
the pole gets striped and that's because
the network does not fully understand
like where the zebra ends and the rest
of the world begins and so there's a lot
of really cool failures that come out of
that like this one
so this is like if it weren't enough you
know if that picture weren't hideous
enough now they've turned him into like
a Marvel Comics supervillain yeah
something like that just having fun
there's a lot of things I'm kind of
running out of time so I'm going to go
really quickly curious but like you can
do like neural captioning of images so
here this is a woman with a smile you
guys recognize her so this is doing live
captioning of the Atlas V D Atlas the
next generation video you guys see this
work last year from Boston Dynamics
making the humanoid robots so I mean
these things are really scary but you
know we can have a little bit of fun by
captioning them so this is a so this is
a person on skis or something like that
a person on skis through people and skis
of course captioning deep dream so
that's the head of a dog or a bird and
you know there's dogs in deep change I
hadn't noticed you know this is a this
is a video made by this guy on YouTube
proofs grocery trip and so this is just
captioning mostly dogs of course as you
can see but if you look here closely
there's going to be a my favorite is
this is there's a third is right there a
school bus it's like a bus the bus is
yellow the Magic School Bus
so yeah just having fun with these
captioning systems this is another demo
that you can do basically live live
detection of objects so here's persons a
lot of persons a leader did you know one
of you is a leader
and definitely traveler
[Music]
who inhabitants is another one it has
this sort of like hierarchical it's like
it's a hierarchical classes so if it
isn't sure what it sees it'll it has
like if it isn't sure what kind of an
animal it is it'll be like oh it's above
it or an ungulate and I'm doing it I
think has feet I think something with
feet and if it's totally unsure
it just says vertebrate this is a
vertebrate you can do this on your
screen pixel so I have software for
doing this not actually in Python so I'm
cheating a little bit sorry but you can
do this but there is actually versions
of this in Python as well just the one
I'm using right here is not not just in
pythons and see but you can do it on
your screen pixel so here I'm like
captioning live YouTube or Facebook live
watching soccer matches Skype this is
always entertaining to put boxes around
people to show people on skype kind of
freak them out I should save some time
for for Q&A so I'm going to skip a few
things wave nets are something that lots
of people should really look up this is
audio generated by oh I forgot to do
this you have to turn on the audio
anyway well the point is wave nuts you
can generate audio which is really
really a neat thing and there's an
implementation for wave nuts no neural
audio generation right and there's a one
that was came up by deep mine but deep
mine did not really software for it just
yet good we're working on working on
taking in all sorts of different
directions but there is an open-source
version of it in tensorflow which has
had lots of contributors and people kind
of trying to reverse engineer this let
me skip that and I'll really quickly say
just a few words about something I'm
working on and Ruby mentioned it earlier
I've been teaching lots of classes I've
been working with a lot of artists and
designers and just people interested in
using machine learning for artistic and
creative purposes just yesterday I had a
workshop at the photographer's gallery
one of them just lots and lots that I've
had and they're all all the resources
that I've been making are totally
open-source part of this website called
ml for a github dial which is a website
that I've been that has
the first thing you'll notice is that
there's a book in progress book about
machine learning for artists so there's
chapters about how neural networks were
kind of really starting from building
blocks and building up people's
understanding of them it's being
translated into multiple languages it
has demos written in JavaScript that you
can kind of step through and neural
network and really kind of go at your
own pace to understand how these things
work there's a whole section of guides
which are a bunch of ipython notebooks
for doing various things with mostly in
Kerris and tensorflow
so for example here's some of the
notebooks how to train your own
convolutional neural network to
recognize handwritten digits this is
like an annotated example of the one
that Karis comes with how to do things
like reverse image search
so query image and then get merest
neighbors how to make tea sneeze of
images so here's a teeny of it's kind of
hard to see but related images kind of
grouped together according to you know
some similarity and how to do is sort of
X degrees of separation this is another
thing that I mentioned Mario Clingerman
did Mario did a so you see this is like
going from the lamp to a tortoise and
kind of fitting images in between so the
sort of X degrees of separation is a
really cool project that you guys should
look at online I don't have enough time
to show it at the moment but if you look
for art experiments of Google this is a
work by Mario Clingerman where he
basically made a it lets you pick two
images from a collection from a museum
collection and then find a sort of path
through a convolutional neural network
feature space that you know kind of
effectively you can kind of see what's
going on here right it finds like the
pads or shortest path between the two
images and then just fun things like
neural network painter so you can make
neural networks fit colors of images and
then do sort of just fun interpolation
he's actually much simpler than they
look so there's a dog being converted by
a neural network into a cat there it is
so things of that sort
I've also taught many many classes and I
put some of them online so these are all
like if you're interested in the subject
you can go and download these from you
too
move their annotated with sections and
segmented and kind of demonstrating a
lot of these concepts as applied to art
art and creativity
so that's ml for a build of course on
top of a huge collection of primary
sources and teaching a lot as well and
lastly having workshops as I mentioned
before so all of this stuff is online
you can find me on Twitter at Jean Cogan
and my website is Jean coca calm
I'm Alfredo github that IO features
basically everything that I showed today
and a lot more it's kind of the tip of
the iceberg and also on Twitter so if
you do if you're interested in the stuff
please do get in touch with me I'm
always interested in hearing more from
people that are interested in applying
machine learning skills to something
we'll never make any money with so
please do talk to me about it so thank
you I know I went a little bit over time
but I think we have a few minutes if
there's any I think we have a couple of
questions that does anyone in the
audience have a question and I'll do a
quick repetition or actually -
microphone on for you to go around the
toes but if you're a pop your hands and
ask something then please go
right yeah yeah
senior microphone I am great talk
awesome it just wanted us is there any
scope of financial success in this field
what are you really from we can even is
any any scope for making money in this
field so I really broke I I should say
I'm joking a little bit I do make money
so like I've been teaching workshops and
you know that there's that is there is a
path to making money with these are
obviously like I'm not mad
like you'll make a lot more money if you
apply your skills for you know financial
services and things like that it's not
as fun though that's what I think but
there is there is definitely an emerging
in emerging ecosystem for making money
with creative uses of machine learning I
mentioned companies like Adobe and and
other companies working with designers
and artists to make software that lets
you do sort of work with with visual
systems so it's much smaller that
there's no getting around that that that
sort of tragic fact but it's growing a
lot and there's a very small pool of
people actually so there's a lot of
opportunity if anyone's interested up
see I just joined a company and a lot
colonoscope created a I don't know kind
of what tools alchemists designers
professors we're currently hiring Lahari
chess so you can console create make
sure yeah
yeah Ruby knows better than me roll beat
and will be actually working a little
bit with creative and litter and then
next thing every step 5
and I had learn more any more questions
one cigar human yes
what I'm sorry what is that - who
Hollywood oh oh I see yeah alright yeah
someone made a comment along those lines
after I posted the Trump thing so later
we'll we'll just be able to impersonate
Brad Pitt you know you get a voice actor
and you know just a person and then you
completely restyle them that's well I
don't think we're there just yet but in
the future yeah we'll have to really
rethink you know once you can
impersonate anyone in the media we'll
have to rethink a lot about what that
means for exactly what you just
mentioned yeah we're getting yeah all
right I think we face the question
succeed you can be around little bit
late for as well therefore the optimal
questions in the meantime achieve you
have like a little fangs thank you for
you I'm soaked about to see you again
[Applause]
[Music]